hi i'm paul feig i'm the writer and
director of today's oscar spot and you
are on Hennessy Street on the backlot of
Warner Brothers the concept is something
I've always felt about the Oscars which
is I'd love the Oscars since I was a kid
and always from as long ago as I can
remember I always wanted to be able to
go to it and when I wanted the message
of this video to be is like basically
you know Ellen's so great she's of the
people and I wanted the message to be
basically that everyone gets to go to
the Oscars this year it's a dream come
true
because I'm a am a huge fan of Ellen's
and I love what she does and I love the
way that she doesn't the persona she
puts forward in the way that she treats
people and the causes that she's she
supports and then the Oscars is
obviously I mean I have to pinch myself
I was just got into the Academy this
year I'm now officially an Academy
member and you really do have to pinch
yourself because you grew up I grew up
watching the Oscars I remember as a kid
you know seeing the sting win for Best
Picture and just thinking like Oh like
it just felt like another planet you're
like if I could only somehow visit that
planet someday and now to be working
this intimately with with the Academy
and doing something specifically for the
Oscars it's yeah it really is I mean I
can almost can't put into words how
exciting it is if you're somebody who
loves movies